Popoff under my car Chester Reinhold
Dyson hofer imagines a boy asking his
dad to drive through the parking garage
so the cars roar can echo loudly
Porsches panamera GTS would strike up an
entire orchestra the moment it starts
done that's the sound of the sports
exhaust system and no doubt father and
son have more fun with it than the
neighbors do but is there more to it
than just noise that's what Reinhold
wants to find out the new Panamera has
more performance grooved and vented
brakes 10 millimeters less ground
clearance dynamic chassis control
adaptive air suspension and shift
paddles on the steering wheel all
standard those are the main technical
modifications that set the especially
sporting porsche panamera GTS apart from
its tamer siblings
the panamera GTS is power plant is a
modified v8 aspirated engine with 4.8
liters of cubic capacity 324 kilowatts
of performance and a maximum torque of
520 Newton meters that carries this
Panamera from 0 to 100 km/h in 4.4
seconds with a maximum speed of 288 km/h
GTS stands for granturismo sport the
drive is on all four wheels the brakes
are identical to the ones on the
panamera turbo version a 7-speed
dual-clutch transmission helps put the
rubber optimally to the road whether in
the city country or on the racetrack
the snowpocalypse final says the dual
clutch transmission harmonizes
brilliantly with the big v8 the sport
seats are perfect both front and back
and the rear seats can be folded down
with up to twelve hundred sixty three
liters of luggage space the Porsche
Panamera might be called a sports wagon
the luggage space can make all the
difference to buyers of practical cars
for daily driving when Portia first
presented the Panamera concept with a
front mounted engine and a real trunk in
2009 many were skeptical but with the
second generation Porsche has proven
that tradition sporting pedigree and
practical needs can be brought together
the Panamera's cockpit is much the same
as in the two-seater 911 just as in an
airplane the buttons and knobs are all
within easy reach for the driver
indoors miss of all I know points out
that Porsche rates fuel consumption at
10.3 litres per hundred kilometers and
it's true as long as you're driving on
the Autobahn and don't exceed 140 km/h
but for city driving anything less than
15 liters is unrealistic and it's just
so much fun to hear the Porsche roar and
foam gasket and unhealthy that's blue
bond restriction compania de
you